Trump is at 48 and so 37 points above
his next rival pretty good place for
Trump to be the next rival though is not
Ron DeSantis who had been the number two
candidate for the whole race
the next rival Vivek ramaswami
who's at 11 so not exactly close to 48
but still that's a major major victory
for ramaswamy
DeSantis one point below at 10 percent
Pence at eight which is pretty
impressive actually given Pence's
current tensions within the GOP pretty
impressive that he's at eight Christy
down at four Haley at Force got it two
burgum got the bergamentum bergam
momentum at one ASA Hutchinson at zero
where he belongs we're still in in silly
season of course the reasonable like
this matters though heading into the
debate
which we're not very close to is because
it's going to show you who's got Mojo
it's going to affect the momentum going
into that debate